today we're talking about how you can
grab the new versions of gta 5 for cheap
as well as what you can expect from
tomorrow's playstation state of play
the prices for grand theft auto 5's
playstation 5 and xbox series x and s
versions have been revealed existing
owners of gta 5 and gta online won't get
a free upgrade but there are hefty
discounts for both playstation 5 and
series x and s pre-orders the game is
set to release on march 15th with the
physical editions coming in april on
xbox the gta 5 and gta online bundle
cost 20 bucks a 50 discount from its
regular price of 40 bucks the pre-order
is now live on the browser version of
the xbox store gta online by itself is
available for 10 on xbox a 50 discount
until june 14th on playstation 5 gta 5
is available at 10
until june 14th and gta online the
standalone release is free until june as
well so playstation 5 players can get
both gta 5 and gta online for 10
after june the gta 5 and gta online
bundle will be 40 bucks on playstation 5
while the standalone gta online edition
will cost 20 bucks man how many times
did i say gta in june in that section
there
and speaking of playstation the rumors
were true sony has announced the next
playstation state of play event is
taking place very soon aka tomorrow
march 9. the event will run for about 20
minutes and will predominantly focus on
games from sony's japanese publishing
partners for both playstation 4 and
playstation 5. this could mean updates
on games like final fantasy xv though
it's of course unclear what the
unannounced games will be adding to this
sony also said that a few other partners
from around the world will be featured
as well the bad news depending on who
you are is that we won't see any more
information on the playstation vr2 and
that includes hardware or games so we
should expect more news on that at a
later date the march playstation state
of play will begin at 2 p.m pacific time
5 pm eastern and we'll be co-streaming
it on the gamespot youtube and twitch
channel so make sure you tune in and let
me know what you're really hoping to see
during this event but keep those
expectations in check don't get too wild
no god of war don't get too
wild and in other live stream news there
will be a stream from the upcoming dead
space remake on march 11th according to
the developer mode of studios the event
will offer fans an early look at
development and what goes into the
remake of a game the stream's title is
the sound of fear reimagined audio
developer live stream so it seems like
it'll be heavier on what you'll hear in
the game instead of what you'll see
motive also shared a minute long trailer
on youtube teasing the announcement the
10th clip is similar to the game's
initial teaser and features some
familiar and eerie sound effects a
splicer and a brief look at protagonist
isaac clark but it doesn't reveal much
else based on motive calling this stream
an early look at development it's safe
to say a release date is still a ways
off now dead space is just a little too
scary for me but let me know if you're
excited for that stream in the comments
below and while you're at it let me know
which version of gta 5 you're getting
and how many copies you've owned in all
these years i think if i get it this
will be my third copy yeah my third copy
i'll see you tomorrow